ja willkommen zur digitalen
ersatzsitzung des Seminars über Tugend
Ethik heute möchte ich zunächst auf ein
Video von mir Hinweisen zum Thema
philosophieren Computerspiele oben
rechts mache ich den Link dazu hinein
den habe ich auf der
bild-cologne gehalten diesen Vortrag
dann möchte ich einen Rückblick auf
Judith klar geben in ihrem Buch
ganz normale Laster da sieht man sie aus
einem anderen Buch ein paar Leitfragen
welche Phänomene zählt klar unter die
Laster nun besteht das allen Lastern
gemeinsam und wie verhalten sich Laster
und Tugenden zueinander und die letzte
Frage die verhalten sich Laster zu
liberalen Demokratie wir werden sehen
dass die Autorin Blaster aus einem
politischen
Kontext her analysiert oder ob du möchte
ein paar zentrale
Zitate bringen
sie sagt und zwar ein Anknüpfung an mir
das euch leisten muss und Verrat
ganz alltägliche lasst das sind
und dass sie eigentlich
keine Aufmerksamkeit
an sich gezogen haben denn die Tugend
hat immer
im Zentrum gestanden sie möchte also die
Schattenseiten der Tugenden beleuchten
die Laster das finde ich sehr
überzeugend
und sie sagt
wir müssen uns auf diese ganz normalen
Laster konzentrieren
die sieben Todsünden sind Hochmut zu
Persien
die Wollust
der Zorn
Völlerei der Neid und die Faulheit
jetzt nimmt sie aber die andere lass
deine Blick Grausamkeit heuchel leisten
die sind für sie sehr sehr zentral
und
sie sagt das gerade liberale Demokratien
eine Herausforderung darstellt wenn es
um diese Laster geht denn die sind fähig
uns im gesamten Charakter zu bestimmen
was ist jetzt eigentlich eine liberale
Demokratie muss man sich fragen er hat
Wikipedia eine interessante Definition
gegeben liberale Demokratien sind durch
freie Wahlen Gewalten drin
Rechtsstaatlichkeit Marktwirtschaft
Menschen Bürgerrechte so viel
bürgerliche politische Freiheitsrechte
charakterisiert die durch eine
Verfassung garantiert werden so kann man
eine liberale Demokratie beziehungsweise
sind überallismus charakterisiert
möchte sie auf die Grausamkeit vor allem
eingehen und sie sagt die Grausamkeit
ist für den Liberalismus besonders
problematisch warum weil wir Furcht vor
Grausamkeit haben und die Furcht vor
Grausamkeit die zerstört die Freiheit
und wir haben ein vorherigen Zitat im
vorherigen Folie gesehen welche Form von
Freiheit die liberale Demokratie
garantiert als sie sagt jetzt auch das
Grausamkeit anders verhält als
treulosigkeiten rumlaufen Richtigkeit
Grausamkeit ist zu rätselhaft weil wir
wieder mit ihr noch ohne sie leben
können über dies konfrontiert sie uns
wie nicht sonst unsere eigene
Irrationalität das ist überzeugend
Grausamkeit ist doch eigentlich völlig
unverständlich warum sollten wir grausam
sein
aber jetzt sagt sie diese ganzen Laster
müssen eine Reihenfolge eine Reihenfolge
gebracht hat was das schlimmste man kann
sich schon denken was das ist das ist
natürlich die Grausamkeit
wenn man die Grausamkeit als
unheilsvollstes laste bewährt und dann
die erste Stelle selbst der schlimmsten
Lasten wird man in der Schlussfolgerung
sorgsam darauf bedacht sein seinen
Menschen hassten Zaum zu halten um aus
ihm keine Zorn werden zu lassen wenn wir
erkennen dass Grausamkeit ein ganz
normales Laster ist dann sind wir
geneigt misshandelt also Menschen
hasserinnen zu werden
zwischen dem Katalog des sieben
Todsünden die wir schon betrachtet haben
ihre Betonung stolz und Maßlosigkeit und
der Auffassung die Grausamkeit an die
erste Stelle zu setzen klafft ein tief
ab und das ist sicher
sie spricht von unterschiedlichen
Wertesystem zwischen den sieben Toten
und ihrem Katalog der Rangfolge sie sagt
weiterhin dass liberale Demokratie nur
dann zu einem
überlebensrezept wird wenn wir
die Grausamkeit als Nummer eins der
schlimmsten laste Anerkennung darin
zeigt sich gerade die Notwendigkeit der
liberalen Demokratie
ja sie hat jetzt abschließend gesagt
dass sie ein Streifzug durch ein
moralisches Minenfeld unternommen hat
das finde ich auch sehr sehr treffend
wenn es um diese Laster geht wenn nun
seine anderen jüngeren Philosophie zur
des 20 Jahrhunderts 21 Jahrhundert sogar
nämlich viel Spaß gut
ihr fragt mal nach dem Verhältnis von
Tuten und Lastern wir fragen nach dem
totenbegriff bei Aristoteles
sie sagt gleich zu Beginn viele Jahre
lang wurde das Thema der Tugenden
entlaster von den Moralphilosoph und der
analytischen Tradition merkwürdig
vernachlässigt man ging Stillschweigen
davon aus das ist nichts im Grundlagen
der Ethik gehören
sie möchte also wieder die Tugenden in
die Philosophie einführen vor allem auch
die Laster
sie sagt folgendes dazu jetzt will ich
mich einer These über die Tugenden
zuwenden die ich so ausdrücken möchte
dass sie Korrektiv ist sind also
formendes
der Korrektur sind wobei jede von ihnen
einer bestimmten Versuchung
entgegenwirkt oder ein spezifisches
motivationsdefizit Ausgleich das
interessante Thesen als Korrektiv
wie mit dem Mut und der Mäßigung steht
es mit vielen anderen Typen so gibt es
beispielsweise eine Tugend des Fleisches
nur weil die Faulheit eine Versuchung
ist und eine Tugend der Bescheidenheit
nur weil sich die Menschen so gern
überschätzt die Hoffnung ist eine Tugend
weil auch die Verzweiflung eine
Versuchung ist für die mir ein Kollektiv
braucht wenn jemand alles als verloren
bejammern würde außer wenn es wenn
wirklich eintritt dann gäbe es keine
tugende
sie definiert also Tugenden ganz klar
von der
Herausforderung der Tugend als von ihrer
problematischen Seite auf die sie
reagieren muss wenn du ein Korrektiv ist
dann müssen wir tun immer über die
Gefahr definieren vielleicht auch über
das Laster was sie herausfordert
bei drogenden widergerechtigkeit der
Wohltätigkeit steht es etwas anders weil
sie keine bestimmten Wunsch oder Motiv
entsprechend müssen also es geht einmal
um ein Kollektiv und einer Versuchung
und es geht bei Toten auch und das
Ausgleichen eines motivationsangels
ja das war ein kurzer Einblick in die
neuere Debatte um Tugend und Laster
vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit bis
zum nächsten Sitzung dann in Präsenz